ok bet Jess pigeon boy psychobabble
we're gonna play Tammy's super ethical
PR opportunity okay let me just get this
[ __ ] what's the Senate that's stupid
I don't even know what the [ __ ] that
[ __ ] was okay betcha so it's your boy
psychobabble like i said and i'm writing
this hot [ __ ] right here all the way to
where she gotta go she don't care about
get enough Sun burn because she is the
song right [ __ ] that's what your
basics don't get you gotta be the bird
and not feel the burn you know what I'm
saying anyways look at that pollution
over there what though [ __ ] she'll turn
your [ __ ] into a Jaguar jay says wait
up there no man i'm so [ __ ] far away
why are these missions like 10 years of
life
as soon as God is that supposed to be
cloud its pollution
this house is all [ __ ] up that's okay
then it's okay
said slow
and well we're just like here are we
hello genki Balfanz second Bobby here
bringing you some exciting genki Ball
updates from the genius professor that's
right Zach we've just received word that
Professor Genki hand decided in honor of
dinky bo seven to make a public
appearance on the streets of steelport
and I also hear that the master ceremony
will be escorted by none other than our
current genki ball frontrunner the
leader of the Saints if you want to meet
the genius behind the epic extravaganza
bloodshed and carnage then head to
leather and lace and while you're there
go ahead and pick up a gift suit that's
all of us will be back Hey oh I just
drive him the best fans you know I could
use a [ __ ] suit
[ __ ] where am I split up
mana
a delight that was a special type of
Mary
let her mask
oh they're over there
ah
that has to be embarrassing how do you
like
hey I got that [ __ ]
ok how do i how do i use the thing
oh ok it's left bumper
ok
[ __ ] this is like hard [ __ ] a lot at
that lot of day
ok ok
well he's happy sounds good okay but
that was a [ __ ] fast mission Jesus
that one sexy chick ditch out for
Harambee